[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
[SWISHING]
LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live.
I'm Louis Gray, here from the
GDL studio, in Mountain View,
for what I think is going to
be an exceptional event.
We are talking with the team
from Codenvy, who has created
a cloud-based IDE which
runs exceptionally
well on Chrome OS.
For many of you who know me
online, we've talked a lot
about Chrome and the development
of a web platform
for a long time.
Often, when I talk about Chrome
OS, people are really
excited about its promise, but
there's still a few questions.
What can't it do?
And one of those questions
that often comes up is
development.
Hey, I'm an engineer.
I've got to use my IDE.
I have my standard tools that
I always use, but what about
running these IDEs on Chrome?
And so today, we're going to
talk about precisely that with
the Codenvy team.
I'm joined in studio
with two guests--
Tyler and Steven.
Welcome, and thank you for
joining us at GDL.
TYLER JEWELL: Thank you
for having us, Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: I appreciate
all the work that
you've done so far.
And we're going to deep dive
into that product.
We also have an avid
user of Codenvy.
Joining us from London, from
our Hangout room in Studio
Campus is Addy Osmani.
Good day, Addy.
ADDY OSMANI: Hey.
LOUIS GRAY: Thanks
for joining us.
And I remember we came across
the idea of bringing Codenvy
in studio from the enthusiasm
that you showed around using
it yourself.
Is that right?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah,
that's right.
I absolutely love using
[? Codenvy. ?]
It's one of those really
great tools, a fit.
Something that's been missing
in my workflow on Chrome OS
for quite some time.
And I've been using it for a
few months, and it's been
really great.
LOUIS GRAY: That's cool.
So thanks for joining
us, Addy.
So obviously we have the people
behind the product, we
have an exceptional user
of the product,
then you've got me.
So you got three out of
four-- really solid.
[LAUGHTER]
LOUIS GRAY: So I want
to just talk, real
quick, about Codenvy.
As someone who's not an
engineer, I read about these
things like IDE.
I read about Eclipse, and I read
about Xcode, and I read
about other platforms.
And I really want to understand
when it came to
developing your product,
first, how did
you have the idea?
And what is it that
sets you apart?
How have you looked at the
opportunity that is there
today with Chrome and the web
to start what you've done?
I'm sure you have a presentation
as well.
TYLER JEWELL: Well, first of
all, thank you for having us
here today.
We're just absolutely excited
about sharing what we're doing
with the entire Google
community.
The actual first bits
for Codenvy started
about four years ago.
And it was part of a French
company called eXo Platform.
And they make a collaboration
solution that competes with
Yammer, Podio, and some
other companies.
And they needed to build some
IP that was multi-tenant IP
inside of a Java virtual
machine.
And they had invented this IP,
and they were looking for a
way to test it at scale.
And they had never had 50, let
alone 100 developers, come to
use this system all at once.
And so they were kicking
around some ideas.
And they said, well, hey, what
if we were to build a widget
factory for our platform,
and we did it as
a cloud-based IDE?
And they did it, and they got
about 50 to 100 users.
And these users were really
excited, and they proved out
the IP that was there.
And the users were so excited
about what they experienced
that the engineering team just
kept moving forward with it.
They said, well, what if we
could do this for Java, and
what if we could do
this for Python?
What if we could
do it for Ruby?
And they kept improving it, and
the traffic kept growing.
And in 2011, they said, well
jeez, what if we could take
the code and deploy
it directly onto a
platform as a service?
And they added support for
originally OpenShift.
But quickly after that, it was
Google App Engine, on that.
And the product took off.
So this is one of those
situations where when we first
started with it, it
was meant to be a
technology garage project.
But it turned into something
that was incredibly popular
and useful along the away.
And the traffic took off so
much so that we decided to
take it away from the French
company, create our own
company with it, and that
happened in January.
And we raised some capital--
$9 million.
And we're now a legitimate
business.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
And we often have people come on
Google Developers Live and
talk about how they started
their startup.
How they came out of one idea,
and it morphed into something
else, based on customer
demand.
And it sounds like you
ran into that.
The more features you poured
into this product, it really
became an extensible platform.
Maybe you can take me back to
this idea four years ago about
working on the cloud platform,
as it was.
As we know, just in the last
several years-- you mentioned
App Engine.
App Engine has gotten
exceptionally stronger and
more powerful than it was
just a few years ago.
And now we have new tools all
the time, new pieces of the
web, that enable you to become
more like a standard
application.
Can you help us understand
that-- how the web has grown
underneath your feet
and let you grow?
TYLER JEWELL: Yeah, well, I
think what the web offers to
us is that it's an environment
for instant provisioning
that's there.
And we didn't realize this when
we started building the
product, but we figured it out
at scale, that the problem we
were solving was not that we
were giving developers tools.
But the problem we were solving
is that we were saving
them the desktop administration
pains.
So when developers work with a
traditional IDE like Eclipse,
you're looking at minimum of
time of hours to get to,
"Hello World." And it's not just
because they have to set
up the IDE.
It's also the build system, the
runtime, all the plug-ins
that they've got to
manage on that.
And with web technologies, web
allows us to set up the entire
same environment instantaneously
and
automatically.
So what used to take hours for
"Hello World," we can take
down to seconds with
a cloud-based IDE.
And so when developers start
seeing that instant access
benefit, and it's still inside
of an industrial strength
tool, that affinity actually
wants them
to use more of that.
And that's where the stickiness
comes in.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
And as somebody who uses Chrome
OS as just a boring old
consumer, one of the things I
really like about it is I feel
like every computer
is my computer.
It really doesn't matter.
I love my Pixel to death, but
if it broke tomorrow, I can
just jump on any machine that
has access to Chrome and get
all of my content
back with Sync.
TYLER JEWELL: Sure.
LOUIS GRAY: Is there something
to that, in terms of that
instant on and portability, that
your users have liked?
TYLER JEWELL: I think that the
users like the fact that you
can use almost any browser to
gain access to it, whether
it's a mobile browser or a web
browser that's out there.
It certainly gives them
device portability.
It also gives them team
portability in that they can
bring other members into the
system right away without
having to go through a
configuration exercise of that.
And what we're starting to
discover is that there's a new
class, or a new category, of
developers that are emerging
because of cloud IDEs.
Previously, you had those
people who were primary
adopters of a workbench.
And then you had people who
were kicking the tires,
looking for new tools.
Now there's a new
middle category.
We call them auxiliary
developers.
These are people who are
commuting to work, and maybe
they have a Chromebook.
And they just need something
that's instant access.
It's the hackathon.
I've got two, three, four of my
buddies, and we're going to
spend two or three hours, and
we just want to start coding
and not deal with the set
up of the environment.
There are some large
organizations who separate
work between the back end
and the front end.
And this is a way for the back
end developers to say, here's
an environment for you to start
working on the front end
that's there.
Vacationers, as well.
And so there's all these
auxiliary groups who need an
occasional workbench for certain
types of projects.
But then they also have their
primary workbench for their
permanent projects, as well.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure, and I
understand you brought an
overview of the product.
And maybe you can go through
that now and give us a little
bit more detail on Codenvy.
TYLER JEWELL: OK, we're going
to give a demo here on it.
Why don't I just run through
just a couple of slides to set
context on it.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure.
TYLER JEWELL: And then
we'll do the demo.
So thank you, everyone.
Obviously, we are a cloud IDE.
We think of ourselves as an
industrial strength tool for
developers.
And the problem we're solving
is that there was a LinkedIn
survey done of 1,200 engineers,
and they asked how
do you spend your time
during the week?
And those engineers reported
back that they invest 13 hours
a week just in administering
their desktop.
It's a third of their time.
And we were really surprised
by that.
But these studies actually
hold true.
There's a lot of cost
to managing that.
And depending upon the tool
that you've got, it can
actually be more costly.
And so we thought, hey, there's
actually a better way
to do things.
If you could have the ability
to create any type of
application, anywhere in the
world, off of any device, and
then have your work shared in a
global community, where you
could increase collaboration
on that, then what would
happen is that developers would
spend their time coding,
administrators would spend their
time configuring, and
managers could spend their
time monitoring, there.
And that is why we
built Codenvy.
So Codenvy is a centralized
environment.
And what we did is we took the
logical workspace that was on
the desktop, and then we
decoupled it from its hardware
dependencies and moved it
entirely into the cloud.
Inside of that workspace
is a bunch of things.
It's not just an IDE, but
there's an entire build system
for compiling, testing,
packaging your code.
And there's actually a runtime
inside of your workspace as
well so that you can execute
the code, debug it, and
prepare it for the
[? actual ?]
deployment into a
PaaS as well.
Obviously, the workspace
is entirely
accessible by browser.
And then your project type is
automatically configured,
based upon either the language
that you select or the
production environment
that it's going
to be deployed into.
So the more we can learn about
the type of application that
is being built, the more we
can restrict the system to
prevent failures and
error rates from
configuration down the way.
We're toolchain compatible.
So from within the IDE, you can
deploy directly to a PaaS,
kick off a continuous
integration build, or commit
your code to a code repository
like GitHub or Bitbucket.
And then once the workspace is
there, you then have three
modes of collaboration.
You can do it like WebEx,
which is popular with
instructors and classrooms.
There's a collaborative mode
like Google Docs, that we're
about to demonstrate here,
where you have multiple
cursors in the IDE, itself.
And then there is a factory
concept that allows you to
clone entire work
spaces as well.
And then you can create replicas
that reflect the same
exact configuration and runtime
environment that you
had before.
And that's very popular
for support scenarios.
A developer who is coding,
they have some sort of
syntactical error, they
want some help.
They can take a snapshot of the
entire workspace, post it
on Stack Overflow, and then the
readers of that thread can
click on that and see exactly
what the previous developer
was having at that
point in time.
So with that, we've got
a lot of users.
We're about 75,000 users.
We represent a lot
of Fortune 500
companies on a global basis.
Our users come from all
over the world.
We see people frequently from
China, India, Brazil,
Venezuela, Russia, all the
Nordic countries as well, all
through Europe, and obviously,
the United States, too.
It's possible to build
APIs, web apps,
mobile apps, and SDKs.
Even at Google I/O, we betaed an
Android framework as well,
where you could actually create
an Android app, compile
it, create the Android
packaging, and then actually
run it in a hosted
emulator as well.
LOUIS GRAY: I have started to
see people talk about taking a
complete mobile only approach
to development.
Can I make a mobile app just
on an Android tablet or an
Android phone?
It really seems today almost
like a science experiment.
But it's probable that not too
long from now that that will
be just as standard as a
desktop, with mobile
penetration being as
strong as it is.
TYLER JEWELL: Yeah,
that's right.
I think that when you see this,
the technology that
allows for emulation or any sort
of broadcasting to the
browser is strong enough where
you have as good performance
through that as you would on
your desktop that's there.
So now that that performance
threshold has been crossed,
it's really just a function of
taking all those technologies
that were on a desktop and
providing them in this shared,
instant access environment
here.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
TYLER JEWELL: So I think we're
passed that one threshold.
And we're just moving to the
delivery side of it now.
So I'm going to pause there.
Let's go into the demo.
After we do a demo, later on,
I'm sure we're going to get
questions about our
architecture
and stuff like that.
We come back to that as well.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
We do have a lot of questions
on Moderator.
So we have a number of those
that we will get to, as well
as talking through Addy's own
experience with your product
that really got us excited
about Codenvy
in the first place.
TYLER JEWELL: Cool.
LOUIS GRAY: One thing that you
mentioned, you talked about
the capability of these
machines and the
enhancement to it.
Being on Chrome OS, and I see
Steven, you have a Chromebook
Pixel with you as well, what
is it about Chrome OS that
makes it a compelling machine
and platform for Codenvy?
Is this the realization
of cloud plus cloud,
or what's the story?
[CLEARS THROAT]
STEVEN LE MEUR: I think you can
use the ability to be able
to work from everywhere with
your Chromebook is something
very interesting with Codenvy.
So we should jump to
the demo, probably.
LOUIS GRAY: Cool.
Let's go ahead and
pull up the demo.
TYLER JEWELL: OK, great.
STEVEN LE MEUR:We will
demonstrate the power of being
able to work with your teams
from everywhere you are.
TYLER JEWELL: Cool.
All right.
Steven has just joined
Codenvy.
He's been a lot of the
brains behind the
future product designs.
And we saw that there were
questions already about
where's the future direction
of that?
And he's the man behind
all that stuff.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
So if I want him to talk about
the next generation that you
don't want to talk about yet,
I'll just keep asking
until he tells us.
TYLER JEWELL: That's right,
that's exactly it.
And he will tell you,
by the way.
LOUIS GRAY: All right, so we'll
look for that in about
20 minutes, then.
TYLER JEWELL: You ply him with
another Pixel, and he's going
to just splurge everything
you've got.
LOUIS GRAY: You came
to the right place.
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER JEWELL: So great.
Here's our home page.
It's pretty straightforward.
I'm just going to log in.
You don't have to create an
account through forms.
You can obviously create an
account through OAuth.
And we support the Google
OAuth technology there.
But I want to log into a
particular account here.
And when you log in behind
the scenes, we're
actually loading an IDE.
Your IDE is going
into a cluster.
We actually run up to about 250
IDEs per process there.
So we actually have a
really high density.
But it's going into
a system, and now
I'm part of the community.
At any given point in time,
there is approximately 1,000
developers who are coding,
building, and testing in here.
Your environment is isolated
apart from all the others,
even though we've got a
multi-tenant architecture
behind the scenes.
And the IDE pops up here,
and its design is very
Eclipse-like.
It is meant to be an industrial
strength tool.
There is the concept of
projects in here.
We can either create a new
project or import a project
from GitHub from this.
You can create projects of
many different types, and
we'll just go ahead and Create
New Create Project.
And what we do is we ask you a
couple of details about the
project that you're
going to create.
What language is it?
What environment are you
going to deploy to?
And depending upon the language
that you select, like
if I wanted to do a Rails App,
it certainly selects the
different PaaS providers that
are available for Rails.
And so there's certainly
some matching
that's going on there.
Just to demonstrate a couple of
the capabilities, I'm going
to do a Java Spring app.
And I'm not going to deploy
it to a PaaS.
I'm going to say None.
And that means it's only
going to run in our
runtime here as well.
And just give it a name,
Google Demo, here.
I'm going to just do a very
simple Spring application with
a template.
And now it's loading
the project.
The IDE, itself, has multiple
panes, as you would expect an
IDE to have.
We can give you different
views of your project.
We can certainly give you
different views of the windows
that are available.
And what I'm doing here is I've
got a Project Explorer.
This is a Java application.
And I'm just going to
open that Java app.
And in the lower right
corner, you can see
we're working hard.
And what's going on over here
is that we're parsing the
source code trees.
We're figuring out all the
dependencies across the
different libraries
that are there.
And eventually, the editor is
going to clean itself up.
Right now, when it opened up,
it's giving me all sorts of
red squigglies, all sorts of
error conditions here, because
it hasn't parsed all the files
in the project that's there.
But after it gets initialized,
this stuff will get cleaned
up, and it's all ready to go.
And this is a completely
workable application.
We can compile it.
We can run it.
And so we'll just go
ahead and do that.
And I'm going to say Build.
And we've got a whole variety
of windows that will show up
on the bottom here.
And so you've got
output windows.
It's going to have a debugger
window that we can show up.
If there's any error codes,
it'll come up here as well.
So you can see that the
build is successful.
Now for the build, we have an
integrated, Maven-based build
system in here.
Maven uses pom.xml as its,
basically, recipe for how the
build should work, with what
dependencies, and where those
dependencies are going
to come from.
We have both a private Maven
repository inside of Codenvy
for all of your local libraries,
but it also can an
access any library that's
available in
Maven Central, as well.
So you can create an
application, reference jars,
SDKs, or other types
of libraries.
And we'll automatically
synchronize with that and
bring them into your workspace
based upon the codes that
you've gotten in here.
Things are fine.
So it's no big deal.
So I'm just going to go ahead
and run, and I'm going to run
the application.
And when it's running, what
actually happens is that the
files are getting synchronized
on the different clusters.
So when we say build, what
happens is all your project
files were synchronized onto a
completely different cluster.
And we've got a series of nodes
that are processing
those builds, even though it
appeared that it was all
happening on one
interface here.
And then the same thing has
happened on the run.
So we've taken the artifacts
that were built, and we've put
them onto a run cluster, and
we've started up a server.
I think in this case, it's
Tomcat running Spring.
And there's a URL here.
And I can click that URL.
I can click that URL, and the
app is now running, and it's
going to load here.
And you'll see that
it's a completely
functioning Spring app.
LOUIS GRAY: And so for some of
that, you literally took the
abstraction, and you virtualized
some of the
complexity.
So what you're showing is the
tip of the iceberg in terms of
all the technology that's
running behind it.
And for the engineer and the
coder who's making the
content, it looks like
any other interface.
But on the back end, you're
doing all of this
synchronization, making sure all
of cluster management is
there, as well.
TYLER JEWELL: That's right.
Yeah, we're trying to give a
desktop-like experience.
But it's actually highly
distributed behind the scenes.
LOUIS GRAY: Well actually, what
it is is many desktops.
It's many different desktops
with only one single monitor.
And that monitor happens
to be a web browser.
TYLER JEWELL: That's
right, yeah.
And if you think about it, when
you're running on your
desktop, you're running many
processes all at once.
So even though it's all on one
node, there's the build
process, the run process, the
IDE process, and we distribute
those processes onto, actually,
separate clusters.
And it actually ends up having,
in many cases, some
users talk about it being faster
than their desktop.
Because if you think about
development, it's highly
sporadic, but very intense
bursts of activity.
And so when you're building on
your desktop, you almost never
use all of the resources that
are available to you.
So when you're working in the
IDE portion, that's a ton of
file manipulation.
And so that's I/O intensive.
But when you're doing that,
the CPU is idle.
But when you say, hey, let's
build my application, it's
very CPU intensive, and now
the I/O is idle, and the
memory is idle.
And obviously, the runs
are memory intensive.
So by separating those onto
separate clusters, you can
actually still use the IDE while
the build is going at
full throttle.
And even though the run is
there, you can use the other
functions as well.
So you can get overall better
performance, and we can throw
a lot more horsepower at each
one of those functions.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
And I think there's always
been this trade off,
especially the last 10 years,
with the capability of
networks increasing so much
further than CPU.
You have this interesting
trade off of it being
CPU-bound versus network
latency.
TYLER JEWELL: Yeah.
LOUIS GRAY: And now that you
were able to abstract all that
on the back end with the
massive clustering, and
hopefully, on the internet
side that the pipe is big
enough for the user, everything
works well in the cloud.
And what are the kind of
questions you get around
connectivity?
We often get that
for Chrome OS.
What apps are online?
What's not online?
How do you handle either
intermittent connection, slow
connection, or no connection?
TYLER JEWELL: So yeah, we get
a lot of questions about the
connectivity element.
The most common question we get
is, is there some sort of
offline support?
And we don't have offline
support today.
But we're working at what would
an offline model be?
Because for a lot of people,
just being able to edit the
files offline is
not sufficient.
They want to be able to compile
them, and they want to
be able to run them.
So offline support for us means
many shades of gray.
So we don't provide
that today.
But in terms of intermittent
connectivity or slow pipes, it
actually is quite good at
the end of the day.
Because if you actually put a
sniffer on it, the amount of
traffic that goes between
the browser and the
server is very limited.
The only time that that sort of
conversation even needs to
take place is when there's
actually a server side
activity, which is essentially
file manipulation, which is
like a refactoring command,
or a build, or a run.
And that's actually very
few and far between.
So we actually do quite well
on slow or intermittent
connections that are there.
And that's how we've
managed it so far.
And we hope that we're about
to year away from having an
offline capability.
And we'll actually use this
Google Packaged Apps
technology to do that.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure, so I don't
want to hijack it and get
interrupting of your demo.
So I want to go through this,
and then I want to transfer
over to Addy to have him talk
more about his experience as
well as possibly JavaScript,
HTML, CSS-- a lot of what the
Chrome fans are looking for.
TYLER JEWELL: No problem.
So here, we ran the app.
Inside the Editor, itself, after
the app run, you can see
that you've got all the things
that you would expect.
You can do code completion
in here.
We can set break points.
We can actually run
a full debugger.
I'm not going to go through
that right now.
You can see that there are
Help on the right.
We've also got Help
on the left.
We can do a lot of interesting
things, like we can refactor
the code if we wanted to.
I could go up here to Edit.
We could refactor that variable
or the method name,
and it'll propagate across
all the factors.
You can generate getters
and setters.
You can send code pointers.
There's a lot of things
you can do.
If I wanted to commit this code
to a GitHub repository,
we've got a full set of
capabilities in here.
The code is running
inside of Codenvy.
It's a local repository
that we've created.
So you could either clone a
remote repository in, or we
could initialize this repository
and then push it
off to GitHub.
And we support all your GitHub
credentials in both public and
private projects in
here as well.
On the PaaS front, we obviously
have a huge number
of PaaS providers
that we support.
Our most popular one, by over
50%, is Google App Engine.
And so when you're done working
with the bits in here,
I could log in.
I could then create a Google
App Engine account--
I have to create a unique
identifier off that.
And then I take all these bits
and push it on there, and
we'll ensure that it actually
is going to run accurately,
because we've restricted our
own environment on that.
We're actually running the
Google Cloud SDK in our local
environment.
So you can make use of all the
APIs that you would have
access to in the Google Cloud
environment here as well.
The last demo we'll get, and
then we can get into Addy, is
Steven, I think, he's going to
log in at some point in time.
And he's going to be able
to join the account.
And so what I would typically
do is I could come in here,
and I could share and
invite developers.
And previous to this call, I
invited him on his email
address into my workspace
here.
And so this is now a shared
work space on that.
So he can join, and I think he's
going to come into the
Google demo here.
And at some point in time,
on the right, he's
going to show up.
And there he is.
He's shown up.
He's got a little red signal
there, meaning that he's not
in the file up, but now
he's in the file.
And somewhere, he's going to
come into the code, and he's
going to start typing.
And oh, he's going to say hi.
Hello, Steven.
Very friendly of you.
Would you like to
code together?
And he's going to just type
some code here or
right after that line.
Put some code in the
[INAUDIBLE].
There we go.
And you can see his cursor
right in the middle.
I could put my [? cursor ?]
over it.
He's going to start typing.
And so we're actually
working on the same
file at the same time.
LOUIS GRAY: Mm-hmm.
TYLER JEWELL: If I were to go
and issue the build, it would
be a simultaneous build
at the same time.
If I were to issue the run, it
would be a simultaneous run.
LOUIS GRAY: And this type of
collaboration is very familiar
to those people who have used
Google Docs as a suite.
You see who's logged in.
You see exactly where
their cursors are.
It's cloud computing
in a new approach.
TYLER JEWELL: That's right.
That's exactly right.
And this is a highly
flexible sort of
collaboration system here.
What we're actually doing behind
the scenes is we're
caching all the files that
are in the project
into a cache server.
And so he's actually running
on a separate
cluster than I am.
And so we're on two
separate IDEs.
And so the cache server is
synchronizing all of our changes.
And then when we do certain
actions, it then synchronizes
the saves back to the
synchronization server across
the different environments
that's there.
So there's actually a lot of
technology that goes into just
making this work at this pace.
And this is what we
provide today.
So we have a large range of
languages that we support.
We have a large range of
platforms that we support.
You're going to see us get a
lot more aggressive in our
expansion--
we've been slowly trickling
things out--
from here on out.
But going forward, we're
just on the verge
of shipping an SDK.
And that SDK is actually going
to allow the community to add
their own languages, add their
own frameworks, add their own
platform as a service providers,
add their own
continuous integration
servers.
And so you can change the entire
system through the SDK.
So we've found that we can
only add one framework or
language a month ourself.
And we can hope to bring
others into it.
And we can make this a system
that's usable by all.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
I really like the expansion when
you talk about using the
SDK as a platform and all these
platforms as a service
that you're supporting.
It almost becomes that your
platform is a new platform.
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER JEWELL: Yeah.
LOUIS GRAY: We must go deeper.
So Addy, I definitely thank
you for being so
patient with us.
ADDY OSMANI: Not at all.
LOUIS GRAY: You got us excited
about Codenvy in the first
place, at least you
did for me.
These guys have been excited
about it for years.
I wanted to have your input,
not just from a user
perspective, which would be
awesome, but really thinking
from the world of Chrome where
you live every day, when you
take a look at the web platform
and HTML development,
CSS, JavaScript, really talk
about how Codenvy has enabled
that for you and for
others like you.
ADDY OSMANI: Sure thing.
So I think there's something
really magical about being
able to build web apps, mobile
web apps, all sorts of
applications and sites on the
web using tools built on web
technologies.
It's sort of Inception-y
in a way.
And I thought that
was really neat.
But I spend a lot of time in
using Git and GitHub every day
in my workflow.
And that's been something that's
been missing for me
when working on Chrome OS.
I've been missing the ability to
be able to open up a Repo,
call on something someone else
has worked on, just being able
to file patches and easily
preview them and maybe push
them off to a different PaaS,
or Heroku or somewhere else
with App Engine and so on.
And Codenvy has really enabled
me to do that.
And it hasn't taken me that long
to actually learn how to
use this and integrate
it into my workflow.
If I happen to be using a Pixel
and if I perhaps don't
have my [INAUDIBLE], or I don't
need it, I can just
easily hop on this and continue
working on whatever
project it was that I was
working on other machines
very, very easily.
The workspace is
already there.
Any commits that I've made are
just instantly accessible.
And the same collaborative
workflow that the guys were
showing a little bit earlier
actually works with GitHub
projects as well as
Repos as well.
So if I happen to import in a
GitHub project where a few of
my friends have been
contributing, and I want to be
able to collaborate with those
friends, it can instantly let
me invite those people, all
the techs who's been
contributing.
I can just send them out a
Codenvy invite and get them
into the project as well.
So we're all collaborating
inside the same workspace.
And I think there's something
really, really
powerful about that.
So I actually wanted
to show two really,
really quick demos.
Is that cool?
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah, absolutely.
We can definitely shift
over to your screen.
And we'll ask Peter in Studio
to make sure that happens.
ADDY OSMANI: Awesome.
Let me know as soon as you
can see my screen.
LOUIS GRAY: We've got
it right now.
ADDY OSMANI: You've
got it, awesome.
So as a modern web app
developer, you probably spent
a lot of time working with
JavaScript, maybe GitHub,
maybe things like App
Engine, or Heroku.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about Heroku really
quickly, and then I'll talk
a little bit more about my
GitHub workflow with Codenvy.
So one of the nice things about
the templates that they
were talking about earlier is
that I can just go and create
a new project.
And if I wanted to, say, start
work on a Ruby on Rails
project, I can go and I can
select the template here.
And in the PaaS section
down below, I
can just select Heroku.
Give this project a name.
Let's call it Unicorn
App or something.
And you can go and click Next.
I can select a template.
I'm hoping that they're going
to expand the templates or
something in the future, but
this works right now.
It's actually pretty neat.
So I can just click on next.
It'll optionally ask me
about my application
name and remote name.
I'm just going to skip those.
And then I can click Finish.
And what this normally scaffolds
you out is actually
a complete small Rails
app that you can go
start hacking on.
All of these are files
you can actually go
in and start editing.
So I've got my Index
file here.
And if I wanted to go
into [INAUDIBLE]
Heroku.
So because Heroku was selected
as the PaaS service, it's
actually gone and created
me a new Heroku app.
So if I went over to my Heroku
account, I would actually
already see the app in there.
And I'd be able to preview
what that looks like.
So this is just a very
empty Heroku app.
If I wanted to push this current
code base and scaffold
it out over to Heroku, it's
really, really simple.
I just go to Get,
Remote, Push.
And when that's loaded up,
I just click on Push.
And what normally happens is
it opens up this little
Progress box at the
very bottom.
It just tells me that it's
successfully pushed to my
Heroku app, and I then have the
updated version of what
was scaffolded out ready
and previewed for me.
Now if I went in and I was to
actually make any changes to
this, I can easily go back
into the Git menu.
I can commit any
of my changes.
I can reset.
I can add, and do most of the
things that I'm going to be
using on a daily
basis in here.
Now moving on to talking a
little bit more about Git and
GitHub, if you happen to love
working within your shell and
you need access to
that, Codenvy
actually has its own shell.
So you can click on Shell
inside the IDE.
So I'm just waiting
for it to load up.
Can you guys see the shell?
It's this black screen.
LOUIS GRAY: It's a five second
delay on the screen.
ADDY OSMANI: OK.
LOUIS GRAY: There we go.
We see it now.
ADDY OSMANI: Anyway, while I'm
waiting for the shell to load
up, basically, what it lets you
do is get access to a ton
of commands that you can use
on your local workspace.
So I'm just going to type
in Help on this.
Can you guys see it yet?
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah, we do see
the shell terminal,
absolutely.
ADDY OSMANI: Awesome, great.
So if you type in the Help
command, you can actually see
what's supported inside
this shell.
And you'll see that there are
a number of Git commands.
There are some other commands
that can help you work with
specific back ends and your
general workflow inside a
Codenvy app.
And I just felt that
was really neat.
I hope that someday you'll be
able to do things like maybe
use NPM and all sorts of
other stuff in here.
But I'll ask them about that
a little bit later.
Another thing that I found
really awesome was the ability
to work with GitHub projects
very, very simply.
So if I go back inside my IDE
window, and I go to Projects,
New, and then Import
from GitHub--
now what this is going to do
is it's going to go and
basically fetch all the
different organizations that
I'm a part of on GitHub and all
the different Repos that I
might be a part of.
Just a list.
And I'm then able to actually
select a specific organization
or account.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to select
my own GitHub account.
And there's a little application
that I wanted to
play around with in Codenvy
called Angular Shopping Demo.
So I'm going to select Angular
Shopping Demo and just Finish.
I think it's going to ask me to
close the current project.
One second.
It's going, and it's
cloning this.
It's going to ask me what
type of project this is.
So it's a JavaScript project.
I'm just going to
click OK, here.
It's then going to go.
And it's going to ask me if I
want to close the existing
project and open up the new
one that I just cloned.
And I can now go and actually
start working on this app.
So one nice thing I noticed
when I first used this was
when you open up a mark up file,
you can actually go to
the Run menu and Show Preview
to get a preview of your
application without
even having to
go deploy it anywhere.
And I thought this
was really neat.
So I can actually make changes
and see them live on my screen
without having to go
really do anything.
So this is a preview
of my application.
Just to show you that it's
working, I'm going to make a
few, very minor [INAUDIBLE]
[? reactions ?]
in here.
But one problem I've got is this
is actually just hosted
on my master branch of
my GitHub repository.
And I'd love to actually be able
to share the URL for this
with other people.
And so I want to be able
to push this project
up to GitHub pages.
Now if we go to another tab that
I have open, this is a
tab that's got 404 in it,
if you go over to it.
This is where I hope my
GH pages version of
this app would be.
But it's not, because I haven't
actually pushed it there.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to fix this.
We're actually going to push
the application into there.
And just for kicks, we're
also going to
make some minor changes.
We're going to change the H1
on this page to say Unicorn
Shopping, instead.
And I'm going to then
save that change.
It'll show me a little dialogue
that says, "Updating
Content."
And then I go to the Git menu.
I'm just going to commit this
change, just so I've got a
record of it.
So made it more awesome.
I'm going to commit
this change.
And I get a little status
update about it.
And then what I'm going
to do is I'm actually
going to go to Git.
I'm going to click on Branches
just take to take a look at
what branches I've
got available.
And I see that I do have a
GitHub Pages branch available
on my repository's origin.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to go to Git,
Remote, Push.
And I'm actually going
to push from Master
to my GItHub Pages.
Now what this is basically going
to do is it's going to
take all the files that I'm
working on at the moment in
Master, and it's just going to
push them up to GitHub Pages.
There may be a little bit of
latency when it comes to how
soon that's active, but
I'm hopeful it's not
going to take too long.
So I'm just going to
press Push on that.
And it says that it successfully
pushed it there.
Let's see if the GitHub gods
are with us today.
And what you should hopefully
see, if there's not too much
latency on this call, is that
my app has actually been
pushed to GitHub Pages,
and it's working fine.
I'm going to buy myself some
pants and some shirts and
other things.
I can start interacting
with this application
a little bit more.
And everything works.
Now you might be wondering, what
if I want to start using
things like NPM modules in here,
and I want to be able to
interact with that?
I haven't really been able to
figure out how to do that in
the Codenvy workflow just yet.
I'm hoping that it's something
that may come sometime in the
future, if it's something, I
guess, that's popular enough
or is a priority for the team.
But other than that, I've
actually been able to work on
a lot of different GitHub
projects directly inside of
Codenvy without having to go
back to the command line or
worry that I'm not in a complete
environment where
I've got access to the
command line and all
of that other stuff.
So I'm really happy with
Codenvy, so far.
I know that they've put a lot of
work into it over the past
few years, and it's only just
going to get better over time.
So yeah, please check it out.
That's my recommendation.
I think it's amazing.
LOUIS GRAY: Well, thanks
very much, Addy, for
going through that.
Hopefully, you got a lot of
feedback in terms of Codenvy--
what he likes and some future
enhancements it sounded like
he was asking for.
TYLER JEWELL: We need
to hire him.
[LAUGHTER]
LOUIS GRAY: Well, he's
not available.
[LAUGHTER]
LOUIS GRAY: We have
a non-poaching
clause here on GDL.
TYLER JEWELL: Ugh.
LOUIS GRAY: You can't get any
of the GDL employees.
But we might have you
guys fill out a
form on the way out.
That's how it works.
As long as you want
to work together,
why not work at Google?
TYLER JEWELL: Wow.
LOUIS GRAY: So we'll talk about
that after the show.
TYLER JEWELL: That's awesome.
That was a great demo.
Thank you, Addy.
ADDY OSMANI: Thank you.
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah, Addy's one
of the real big experts in
terms of the web platform
and Chrome.
We always go to him for any
of the tough questions.
So I'm glad he's really
found your program
and platform valuable.
So we have a number of questions
in Moderator.
And I know both you and Steven
are going to go through those
and really talk about not only
what Codenvy can already do,
but possible directions
that it can go.
And I know many different people
have their own favorite
coding environment, their own
languages that they need for
their platforms.
And so, not surprisingly, that's
where a lot of these
questions come from.
So we'll start at the top with
one of the more exciting
languages to come out of late,
which is the Dart platform.
And the first question comes
from a guy named Chill Fox, in
Australia, if that is his real
name, and he asks, will
Codenvy get support for Dart?
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER JEWELL: Well first, inside
of Codenvy, we've got a
lot of people there.
And I've made the proclamation
that I believe in five years
that Dart will actually
supplant JavaScript.
I think it's the modularity
of it.
I think the fact that you can
have a compile phase that runs
inside of a VM-- there's just
a lot of enterprise benefits
that come from that.
So we believe that.
We will get Dart support.
Now, the way that we're going to
add Dart, and this is also
the same that goes true for Go
support as well, is we're
going to publish the SDK.
We're also going to publish with
that all of our examples.
We will have ported PHP, Python,
Ruby, and all of the
Java components to that.
And we're going to then rally
the community around making
use of that SDK.
And we'll then come up with some
sort of governance model
where we can then bring those
languages and frameworks in.
And I actually think Dart is one
of the earlier ones that
needs to happen.
Because it would be exploitable
with this type of
architecture, partly because
it's not just Dart, the
language, but there's
also Dart to JS.
So there's a compilation phase,
which makes it really
suitable for a build-based
system that's there, whether
it's Maven or we go with a
different sort of system.
Who knows on that?
But then on the runtime,
we can take a Chromium
environment, actually run that
local, execute your Dart app,
so that you don't have to
leave the browser all
together, even though it's a
full, enterprise-oriented
mulit-dependency Dart
application, if you will.
So that's going to be
our path to that.
In terms of time frames on this,
the SDK is going into
beta next month.
We're going to have that
be a controlled beta.
We've got about a dozenish
partners who are working with
us on that.
And then it will definitely
be published before
the end of this year.
So I think we need a couple more
months, and then we can
get optics on exactly when
some of these important
languages are going
to show up.
LOUIS GRAY: Cool.
So you say next month.
Next month is actually
pretty quick.
TYLER JEWELL: What's
today's date?
[LAUGHTER]
LOUIS GRAY: We're
still in June.
TYLER JEWELL: Oh, OK.
LOUIS GRAY: So sometime in
July is what I'm hearing.
TYLER JEWELL: Yeah.
LOUIS GRAY: Even with
the July 4 holiday?
TYLER JEWELL: Well, we do our
engineering in Europe.
LOUIS GRAY: So they don't
celebrate our
independence much?
TYLER JEWELL: They
don't understand.
LOUIS GRAY: OK.
Because I know often here at
Google, things start to slow
down next week.
And we'll keep track of that.
Very cool.
So you talked about Dart.
You talked about Go.
Obviously, those are two
languages we talk a
lot about on GDL.
The Dartisans community is
exceptionally passionate.
And I like your projection
of Dart taking over where
JavaScript is in not too long.
I know a lot of people here
will be happy about that.
And we really hear the
advantages of that every day.
So it's good to hear you're
talking about it.
There's another question around
your actual design.
Some people like the IDE.
Some think it needs a little
bit of a bump up.
What can you talk about in terms
of the look and feel of
the IDE for Codenvy today?
STEVEN LE MEUR: Maybe the first
point is that it's a
tool for developers.
So it must feel something
like robust, solid.
And I think it's delivered
this message.
And maybe the point is that
we should make it
a little more modern.
So that's definitely something
that we will work on.
But we should take the time
to deliver something
great to our users.
And for sure, we will work with
all our communities to
get their feedback on what they
like, what they don't
like, and what we can improve.
So I think it will be a
collaborative way to do the
work on the next version of
the design for Codenvy.
LOUIS GRAY: So you mentioned
where the
development takes place.
But there's another type of ware
that I'm curious about
with Codenvy.
Do you make Codenvy
with Codenvy?
TYLER JEWELL: We do.
LOUIS GRAY: You do?
TYLER JEWELL: Yes.
LOUIS GRAY: So how do you
compile to itself--
TYLER JEWELL: It's painful.
LOUIS GRAY: --withouth going
into an infinite loop?
TYLER JEWELL: OK, now you're
just geeking out, all right?
So it's painful, because
Codenvy is
actually built with GWT.
LOUIS GRAY: Mm-hmm.
TYLER JEWELL: And for those of
you who's used GWT, there is
dev mode and there's non-dev
mode with GWT.
And if you're in non-dev mode
with GWT, it's about 11
minutes to compile
your application.
And that's certainly
not a workable
fashion that was there.
So if you're in dev mode, you
get incremental compilation,
which is a workable answer.
And so we had to do a lot of
work to basically take the dev
mode, which only works in
Eclipse, and make that
workable in our environment
there.
And so it's Maven-based.
We actually support Maven
multi-module, so that you can
decompose all the work to
different team members.
So we've got that work
decomposed in that.
We use a Maven multi-module
project.
The builds run on a local
Codenvy instance that the
public doesn't have access to.
It's in our environment
that's there.
And then the output--
and we have the ability to
route output to different
acceptance servers, staging
servers, and whatnot, there.
But we recognized, when we
decided that we were going to
make this into a commercial
entity and that it was going
to stop being a garage project,
that we were never
going to get real global
adoption unless we could go
out and tell the world that
we were using it--
eating our own dog food, as
well, or drinking our own
champagne, as the French
like to say it.
LOUIS GRAY: Uh-huh,
much better.
TYLER JEWELL: Yeah, and so
last fall, we told the
engineers, well, come summer,
you've got to use it.
So they put the things
in there that they
needed to make it work.
LOUIS GRAY: Godd, I hoped
that was the answer.
So there are some questions
around the mobile presence.
I think we talked about coding
on mobile, and we addressed
that somewhat earlier.
Is there anything else you
want to say, in terms of
mobile presence, for Codenvy?
TYLER JEWELL: When they say
mobile presence, are they
talking about accessibility
through a mobile device or
development of mobile apps?
LOUIS GRAY: You'll have to
ask Daniel from Tacoma.
All he says is, what mobile
presence will Codenvy have?
TYLER JEWELL: OK, well I'll talk
about the accessibility
over mobile.
And then I'm going to let
Steven talk about using
Codenvy to build mobile
applications.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
TYLER JEWELL: So in terms of
accessibility, because the
product there's two things-- we
do a lot of right clicking
inside the product, and the
product is structured a
certain way.
It's not really touch ready.
So we need to have a
special browser.
So we use Puffin web
browser on that.
We're certified on that.
And that gives you a simulated
right click that
you can use on that.
And so we have a lot
of apps who are
built that way on that.
Also, you can actually access
and create apps on an iPhone.
It's not the best experience
in the world.
But there is that
accessibility.
It's not shaped for the iPhone
screen resolution, but it is
navigatable in that regard.
So that's on the accessibility
front, and I think we'll just
incrementally improve that for
different screen shapes and
different input devices
over time.
In terms of using Codenvy to
build mobile apps, we've got
two things that we're
working on--
Trigger and the Google
project.
STEVEN LE MEUR: Yeah.
So we have some few things in
our roadmaps on making it
possible to build an application
on a [? formal ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
directly from Codenvy.
So we will do that.
We will add some cool
stuff to demo later.
We already demoed during
Google I/O.
But in fact, the idea is for
an Android application, for
example, you will be able to
develop, to get access to the
Android SDK directly
from Codenvy.
And you will be able to deploy
on the emulator directly on
the web, and also directly
on the device.
And we will put something, a
QR code that you will scan,
and it will install the
APK on your device.
So there's a few things that
are coming and that are
already in our roadmaps.
LOUIS GRAY: Great, fantastic.
Now, we actually talked about
a couple of the questions,
already here.
One of the questions is around
running as an offline IDE.
I believe we addressed that.
There's another question around
the limitations and
stipulations applying to Open
Source Premium Account, and
what languages and libraries
will be available at launch?
Additionally, what language and
library support will we
see in the future?
TYLER JEWELL: So the way our
pricing works on the public
cloud is that it's free for
unlimited number of
developers, as long as your
projects are public and you're
OK using shared build
and run queues.
If you need to have private
projects or a dedicated queue,
which gives you guaranteed
access, then you have to be on
a premium plan.
Our premium plans all have the
same functionality, but they
are different prices based
upon whether you're a
commercial entity,
an individual, or
an open source project.
We give it away for free to
open source projects.
And the conditions there are
that you've got at least three
committers and that the project
has been accessible
for at least six months there.
So we're looking for
that it's an
established project on that.
In terms of what sort of
libraries are available, any
library through Maven Central
is currently available.
You can also upload your
own libraries.
There's a technique that you
can use where you can
basically upload files into your
project space, and then
those files are locally
accessible as a library.
And that actually works for Java
type projects and other
projects as well on that.
And then did I capture
all that?
What's coming in the future?
LOUIS GRAY: Yes.
TYLER JEWELL: There's a lot
coming in the future.
There's some stuff that we're
going to ship very, very
shortly here, which is going
to allow onboarding of
projects and libraries of
many thousands of types.
And it's going to be
really interesting.
We should have that before
the end of summer.
LOUIS GRAY: Very cool.
And I think that would possibly
make the UI more complex.
So I'm looking forward to seeing
how you handle that.
TYLER JEWELL: It's going
to be less complex.
LOUIS GRAY: Less complex?
More virtualization.
TYLER JEWELL: No, not
more virtualization.
Actually, if you think about
it, the UI we have today
actually makes it more complex
than it needs to be.
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah, I think that
was some of the feedback.
TYLER JEWELL: Well, we have
to make it more modern.
But today, to get to this point,
you've got to log in.
You've got to have
credentials.
You've got to then
create a project.
You've got to know what kind of
project you want to create.
And if you think about it, most
people start off and say,
I want to do an AngularJS
app on Ruby on Rails.
So that should be their starting
point, and we'll make
that their starting point, as
opposed to the other stuff.
LOUIS GRAY: There was a question
here from London--
one of your counterparts,
Addy--
asking about deploying to
a local virtual machine.
Are they able to do that?
TYLER JEWELL: Deploying
to a local, virtual--
LOUIS GRAY: A local VM.
Am I able to deploy
to my local VM?
TYLER JEWELL: Oh, OK.
So I think the feature that
would allow for that is either
an FTP based deployment
mechanism or an SSH.
That's like a secure shell and
some sort of remote VM.
We don't have either those
capabilities today.
It's a very, very frequently and
commonly requested feature
that's there.
So I think that we've been
pretty good about adding
things that are commonly
requested, and I think we'll
get to that.
By the way, for those who are
interested, there is a user
voice site right off
of our Home page.
Click Feedback.
We religiously watch all
the features and the
votes that are there.
So click Add Your Own Request,
vote, vote, vote.
We love it.
We listen to it.
We obsess about it.
LOUIS GRAY: Well, it sounds like
listening to customers is
a good idea.
And it sounds like you're
doing that.
There's another comment over
on the YouTube side from G.
Hussain Chinoy Asking about
Gradle support.
Is there Gradle support
or only Maven?
TYLER JEWELL: There's only
Maven, but before the end of
the summer, we'll have both
Ant and Gradle as well.
Those will be both native
build support.
LOUIS GRAY: And Jorge, also on
YouTube, is asking, what is
the bandwidth recommended
to use the application?
TYLER JEWELL: Recommended?
I don't think we have actual
specs, but it's going to run
just fine on like a sub
megabit connection.
LOUIS GRAY: Submegabit?
TYLER JEWELL: Submegabit.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
TYLER JEWELL: Yeah.
LOUIS GRAY: OK.
I don't want to try that out,
because I don't want to have
submegabit.
But I believe you.
TYLER JEWELL: I think the only
time you get into a couple of
issues is that we use WebSocket
technology to handle
communications back and forth.
And so if you have a very
intermittent connection, it's
possible that the editor loses
its connection to the server,
and the code is not
automatically saved.
So what we'll do to resolve that
is we'll allow people to
go back into a non-performant
mode, like a default mode,
where every time you have
to manually save.
And if it doesn't save, then you
know you've got a problem
sort of thing.
LOUIS GRAY: Now you brought up
your presentation at Google
I/O. Marlon Jones, over on the
YouTube side is asking about
another introduction that we
did a Google I/O, which was
the Google Play Games API.
He wants to know if it's
possible to use the new Google
Play Games API with Codenvy?
TYLER JEWELL: Do you know?
I don't even know anything
about the API.
STEVEN LE MEUR: Yeah, this is
an API for all games on the
[INAUDIBLE] and iOS
and [INAUDIBLE].
TYLER JEWELL: Oh.
STEVEN LE MEUR: So probably,
we will, after the features
that we will deliver next month,
we will be able to
leverage the power of these
APIs through our factory.
So you want to make your project
with these APIs, it
will be very easy for
the onboarding.
So it will be super easy to make
your mobile applications
based on these APIs.
TYLER JEWELL: Do you know what
the format of the API?
LOUIS GRAY: We have other GDL
events that talk about Google
Play Games API.
So definitely you'll want
to check those out.
TYLER JEWELL: OK.
LOUIS GRAY: It's
very, very new.
We're really excited about it.
There's a question on YouTube
about game development and
other development, so I think
a more broad question.
What type of applications do you
see users today building
on Codenvy?
What's the most typical type
of application people make?
TYLER JEWELL: Yeah, so I think
the most common things that
people are developing are web
apps that will ultimately
operate in an online PaaS.
That's the most common.
And then the second thing,
a lot of API development.
So people use it to create the
API, publish the API, and make
that API accessible
that's there.
Those are the two most commonly
requested mobile app.
A lot of people want to
use the browser to
create mobile apps.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
Now Addy, I know we still have
you there, and we're coming
close to the end of
our allotted hour.
There's a little bit of
background noise, so I know we
had to turn down your
volume a little bit.
So we'll be sensitive to that.
Is there anything you wanted to
ask the team while they're
here, before we close?
ADDY OSMANI: Sure, so I had a
few questions that I know that
some web app developers are
going to be really interested
in [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm really excited about
things like AngularJS,
Polymer, Backbone,
Ember and so on.
Can developers in those
communities hope to see
templates that will help them
kick start off, in terms of
development of those types of
projects, inside Codenvy in
the future?
TYLER JEWELL: Yeah, I think we
just hired, essentially, a
program manager, much the way
that Google has their own
program managers for working
with the developer community.
And the biggest part of the job
of the program manager is
basically creating these little
miniature, let's call
them template communities that
are out there so that you can
quickly get started with
pretty much any type of
project that you want to get
started with on that.
I think we've done a very poor
job of delivering on the
popular technologies that are
out there, even though Codenvy
today is capable of
working with them.
We just make you go through
the laborious process of
getting it set up.
And we want to just remove
all that out of the way.
So in many ways, we think that
codenvy.com, the site, will
become a listing of all
the technologies that
developers are using.
Which one do you want
to get coding with?
Let's get coding
with that now.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
ADDY OSMANI: That's awesome,
and I know that there are
probably developers out there
that'll be interested, or very
willing, at least, to create
some of these templates for
you, if you're open to community
submissions.
Another question that I had was
around cloud-based device
or browser testing.
So if I create a web app inside
Codenvy, and I want to
then be able to go and see
how it looks inside other
browsers, maybe using something
like BrowserStack or
[? SophosLabs ?] and so on, is
that something that you've
considered, just making it easy
to launch your current
app inside something else?
Or is it something
you'd consider?
TYLER JEWELL: How interesting
that you brought that up.
I think halfway through, we
talked about how we've got a
dozen partners who are signed up
to working in our beta SDK
[? SophosLabs ?]
is one.
So the vision there is that
very same sort of plug-in.
Plug-in, cross browser testing,
maybe possibly even
automatically generate the
Selenium script for that
automatic submission
that's there.
So today, it's code, build,
test for the individual.
But then there's some of these
broader workflows that you can
incorporate in.
ADDY OSMANI: That's fantastic.
TYLER JEWELL: We've got some
other great ones that are
coming, too.
LOUIS GRAY: It almost sounds
like we need to bring you back
in here not too long from
now for part two.
So what I want to do is thank
you guys for coming in.
It's been an excellent
session.
Really taught us a lot.
Hopefully, Addy, it wasn't
too late for you.
So I appreciate your
jumping in.
ADDY OSMANI: Not at all.
LOUIS GRAY:And joining us,
remotely, from the UK.
This really is the power
of being global in live
interaction with our users.
Thank you for all of you
who left comments
on YouTube and Moderator.
I would encourage everybody who
hasn't known enough about
Codenvy so far to go to
codenvy.com to find out more.
Sign up, give it a kick, and
I'd love to see more people
using Chrome OS and other strong
platforms to be coding
directly on the web.
So thanks again, both Tyler and
Steven, for joining me.
You can join us every
single day at
developers.google.com/live
for more GDL content.
And follow us on YouTube
at Google Developers.
See you soon.
[SWISHING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]